on the show you've talked before about
your dad and what an extraordinary man
he was and in the book he really comes
across as kind of a
a superhero tell us about um your bird
yes well we had this was a summer
i guess around 1978 79
um my dad and i were living together in
a trailer park
and we had a bird a cockatiel he loved
this bird and we had a rule you know in
the day in the morning just watch when
you open the door so he didn't get out
and you know when you're coming in the
door make sure you just open it slightly
so the bird didn't get out well the bird
would fly around freely
all day and then we'd get home put it in
his cage let it talk to it let it sit on
his shoulder
he got home one night from work about
the same time i got home from playing
outside
and then where's our bird lucky lucky
where's lucky no lucky lucky we're lucky
he's always here to go where the hell is
lucky i'm looking on one end of the
trailer
dad goes look on the other end all of a
sudden they hear dad start going no no
no no i run back there he's on his hands
and knees over the toilet
and he reaches in lucky's down there and
swirling
lifeless dead in the bottom of the
toilet he reaches in the toilet
dad starts he loves this bird starts
just weeping brings his bird up
soaking in toilet water and then
he grabs the bird by the waist and puts
lucky's head and whole chest in his
mouth and he starts going
tears coming down his eye starts going
very lightly he's a big man he's blowing
like just the right amount of air that
would not blow up a bird's lungs
but enough and i'm watching this and
dad's weeping going
all of a sudden feather flips
brings his bird out lucky shakes the
toilet water off his head and dad's
saliva off his head
he brought that damn bird lucky back to
life that bird was
dead and he like mouth-to-mouth
resuscitation he revived that bird lucky
lucky lived another eight years wow what
a great story
listen i know you've got to go but there
are lots of great stories in
uh green light is out now and if you
want to hear more about the book and
from matthew they're doing a fein event
uh with idris elba tomorrow night
matthew mcconaughey lovely to see you
take care my friend bye-bye
always good to see you bye everybody